freude herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge einen tag persönlicher kocht
ich bin heute bei demand du hast dir als
leckeren frühstück gewünscht und zwar
ein smoothie ich habe eine kleine
erweiterung noch dazu mir überlegt dass
bereich wirst du kannst ja mal spannend
und wir sehen uns leute die bringt
richtig praktisch da ist ein bisschen
wie punkten wieder gesund aus geht die
hand was mich im kopf sehr gerne
ich war jetzt meine tomaten so hier in
vernich den strunk jetzt dürfen wir die
tomaten wundert euch nicht wenn man im
hintergrund mal was hört ist nämlich
sehr viel leben hier
hallo das wird andy würde
es ist eigentlich überraschend deshalb
die firma kurzweg schneidet das ganze
natürlich für großstädter die tomaten
marinieren wir jetzt werden wir alles
weiter machen einfach hier bin heute
morgen sich ganz gut aus dem bett
gekommen dass er musste die mannschaft
so lange nicht warten ich nicht so dazu
zog wir ein bisschen frischem basilikum
ja eigentlich das gefühl dass man wenn
man so leicht verkatert ist dass man
dann so eine andere kreativität beim
kochen hat dazu geben wir so lieben öl
ordentlich was dann habe ich hier eine
sehr schöne brot geholt das einen
dinkelbrot die man ist nämlich wenig
oder keinen weiß dass du perfekt wo ich
liebe das möchte ich dazu einladen da
gehe ich immer dahin die briten auch
relativ teuer aber es ist einfach ein
game changer kommt erkrankt sollte man
dem backofen an dem jetzt hier auf brot
in wenig olivenöl von beiden seiten so
dann kommen wir auch zum
hauptbestandteil stützt dem smoothie ich
habe dafür spinat mango banane zitrone
ingwer und ein bisschen orangensaft und
wir machen das gar nicht groß nach
rezept sondern mit dem erhofften ein
bisschen was dazu nämlich alle super
gesunde
anteile die mag ich gefroren geholt
damit er so ein bisschen kühl ist das
mag ich immer ganz gerne selbst bald
untergehen erst ein bisschen man soweit
dann kommt dazu und banane eine ganze
banane dann erst mal so ein stückchen
ich habe noch ein zweites vorbereitet
schmeckt dass man sie gleich ab und
gucken ob da noch mehr rein sollte indem
wir ein bisschen zitronensaft hinein
dann gegenwert spinat hinein
er kann ruhig ein bisschen mehr rein und
dann ein wenig warten sagt frag mich was
gesagt und dann schmeißen so der
backofen ist vorgeheizt gemäss das brot
rein und lasst uns wie gesagt kurz
andres und 34 minuten schön knusprig so
jetzt mal ein bisschen väter klein und
was so ganz groß so häufig wie rein ins
über das angerostete boden mit einer
frischen knoblauchzehe drüber das gibt
auf jeden fall ordentlich punch also
sonst haben wir keinen knoblauch dran
aber man wird das trotzdem deutlich
schmecken so und jetzt geben wir die
tomate aufs brot oder leute dich zukommt
gut ankommt darüber ein bisschen väter
und balsamico creme
kommen wir zu frühstücken ainring smoby
bekommt bei mir mit verschiedensten
sachen die grünen mag ich am meisten ja
so sache hart und sehr sehr gut also es
gibt ja die beiden lediglich sind diese
fertiges move ist rosarot cooper d mit
spinat ist auf blattspinat genial als
sehr gehört und ihr erstmal die party
schon mal glück gehabt da ist alles
mögliche drin also ich habe einfach
komplettes obst und gemüseregal
aufeinander genau das mit musik damit
natürlich nicht zu viel sagen weil du
musst ja die gesamtnote die dann
überlegen sie tun nichts geileres sehe
ich habe auch vor dem schlachter ich
habe nicht viel gerissen bringen
unbedingt was die schmecken sein
beispiel rein und da geht aber auch die
kamera aus und wir sehen uns erst wieder
wenn du alles auf toiletten
okay wir sind gleich wieder so wie man
durch aufgegessen der teller ist
leergefegt das ist schon mal sehr sehr
gut wir haben noch ein bisschen mehr
stehen falls man mal auf einer augenhöhe
zweite runde kommen ja unbedingt
absitzen bedient ich habe jedenfalls ist
ja mal sehr gespannt was du sagst und
vor allem was du mir gibst ich habe
schon einige bugs in deinem leben
gegessen das heißt eigentlich schon
schwierig das ist im vergleich nachweis
war keine alters nichts gebracht
von 9 bis 10 gehen alle wieder falsch
ist leider so oder weil ich zu wenig
gegessen hat heute aber ich hab' ich
habe ja sowieso dass eine gute strategie
einfach übels lange die mal warten das
material firma gemacht dann schmeckt
besonders rückten aber das hat echt geil
aber nicht falsch machen obwohl unfall
kurz
das letzte mal habt ihr das gar oft
erzählt hört man manchmal ein bisschen
butter drauf ein bisschen diesmal dieses
duos roxette pimpen
also ich gehöre jetzt auch 10.15 uhr
läutete damit lässt sich auf jeden fall
den tag starten wir sehen uns zum
mittagessen freunde willkommen zum
mittagessen ich mache heute mittag eine
superschnelle leckere einfache cremige
vegane tomatensuppe die macht sich von
mir ne super gewünschten der meinte er
mag super g gesucht habe ich ein rezept
gefunden das verspricht dass das richtig
heftig ist und das war es mir natürlich
nicht zweimal sagen gefangen an indem
wir zwei zehen knoblauch fein reiben
dafür habe ich hier so eine vision
muskat bleibe dann schaffen wir das zwei
zwiebeln hier ist jetzt unsere knoblauch
passte wie gesagt die besonderheit ist
dass diese tomaten durch so 15 minuten
braucht also ultraschnell ist deshalb
schreiben wir auch den knoblauch so kann
eigentlich in der kurzen zeit die wir
kommen einfach mehr geschmack abgegeben
werden soll auch schon jetzt ganz feines
schreiben also wirklich so richtig schön
fein so alles schön verein geschnitten
da machen wir schon mal eine fahne bzw
die box geben vier esslöffel olivenöl
hinein
das lassen wir heiß werden aus mir einen
teelöffel chili an in dem öl dann fügen
wir unsere zwiebeln hinzu und unseren
knoblauch jetzt alles schön gleichmäßig
verteilen und aufpassen dass
unsere zwiebel nicht braun werden
niedrige sätze dann zog ich noch ein
bisschen oregano ein regal kann man
natürlich auch super gut getrocknet
verwenden aber ich dachte mir ich mache
hier also die extra professional
variante
man sieht schon förmlich das hier
richtig cremig werden aber nicht die
zwiebeln sind das geheimnis der
cremigkeit von diesem gericht sondern es
liegt schon hier drüben einfaches
sandwich toaster ich habe die man schon
gefragt das ist ok weil das ist
natürlich auch mit weizen dafür macht er
eine ausnahme weil ich glaube ansonsten
wird das schon sehr sehr nice sein
wir schneiden war unsere post die ränder
und dann rufen wir jetzt einfach unser
brot hinein weiß es total wert aber das
gibt die cremigkeit das ist eine große
portion für stimmt acht personen dann
kommen sie wieder auf die hitze und dazu
kommen unsere tomaten und zwar verwenden
wir geschälte tomaten in der eigenen so
soll euch jetzt gesehen vier dosen
formaten sind erst dann würden wir das
ganze mal durch wenn man sieht wie man
habe ich noch nicht unbedingt eine
tomatensuppe denken sie gehen ein
bisschen mehr hitze war ich mache mich
viele bewährte ein liter wasser ist
übrigens an der seite und auf die finger
zu schauen was ich hier mache und ich
hab hunger
ich habe hier mal ein bisschen durch die
tomaten bisschen feierlich aufpassen mit
der sehr teuren pfanne alles jetzt quasi
einmal aufkochen das ist so die übelste
großfamilien portion und ich hier
gemacht haben
und das kommt dann gleich nachdem es
aufgekocht und gewürzt wurde in den
mixer und wird dann zu einer cremigen
tomatensuppe da wird es noch garniert
mit basilikum aber ihr merkt schon
wirklich ein superschnelles flottes
rezept wie immer vom besten man höchst
efk entschied so jetzt muss ich das
ganze abschmecken und ich sage euch eins
leute brauchen mit jede menge seit ich
weiß gar nicht ob das ausreichen wird
also let's go wieder voll da geht hier
vor gänzlich sei es rein leute da können
sie noch drei wochen von essen
ja dann noch frisch als helfer dazu auch
davon eine ganze menge dann machen wir
den herd wieder auf so freunde dann wird
es auch schon zeit was in den mixer zu
schützen ist es wirklich unglaublich
viel eher hätte man sich ja irgendwie
gehen können vielleicht nehme ich mir
besser so eine suppenkelle nicht zu voll
machen dann machen wir den deckel drauf
kann mich langsam an zu kurieren
irgend welchen stücken
sehr gut sehr schöne farbe ist dann
können wir unsere super auch schon in
einen teller geben so ein wenig olivenöl
nochmal drüber und ein bisschen frischer
basilikum obendrauf
unsere software ich halte eine liegen
alle leider angelegt ist auf erziehung
für dich und nicht gern ich kenn ich
weiß nicht ganz glauben verteilung ist
aber es ist auf jeden fall besser als
alte leute alleine schon aussieht ich
finde alle in dem haus ist eine
bewertung geben aber ich war natürlich
bis zum ende auf den geschmack der wurst
das an richtig gelernt sich geld
mindestens für und probiere gerne mal
gespannt
aber natürlich nicht zu viel sagen im
moment sehr schwach schlossen typ der
ohne brot keine super essen kann
obwohl hat eigentlich müsste man es auch
köln war im boot gehabt so super dazu in
der suppe selbst brot drin sogar so viel
nämlich so ich würde an dem jetzt direkt
sagen uns gleich wieder
wir haben auch gegessen wir haben sogar
unsere teller aufgegessen und sie sind
nicht mehr hier einfach komplett sowie
dieser kaugummi werbung glänzte das noch
ich bin gespannt was du sagst ich legt
dann vielleicht habe ich gekauft werde
von ihr alter halt machen
ok also du hast so du hast dir selbst
über gewundert dass die gal der schwefel
deswegen ist ja ich bin auch schon
einige begannen sich philippe gar nicht
schon gemacht hat findet damit sind noch
plätze stellt aber zusammen mit und lass
es hat einfach gehen die heimischen
quartier beim italiener fest weil so
einfach wieder die leute jetzt muss ich
mich aber turbo und renk wir machen
heute abend packte das erst dann werde
ich aber kritisch sogar willst dann
musst du kritisch sein aber ich werde
alles geben um auch da noch mal alles
rauszuholen
das ding ist halt das ist glaube ich das
bekannteste thailändische gerichten ist
doch mein lieblings als sie hat sich das
gerichten wurden da werde ich wirklich
einiges erwarten aber ich denke es ja
gleich gesagt hat dass hinzubekommen
leute ich bemühe mich auf jeden fall
bisher zum mega viel spaß gemacht beide
sachen die wir gemacht haben waren super
lecker und wir sehen uns zum abendessen
partei braucht unter anderem erdnüsse
ich habe normale erben kauft braucht
aber gerüstet
das geht sehr schnell und wir nehmen so
eine gute handvoll erdnüsse der geehrten
müsste anrösten körperliche störungen
unseren toten
dann nehme ich diese gesagte packung und
zwar schneiden wir den tofu so in so
schönen mundgerechte stücke man hessen
eine vegetarische version konnten partei
beziehungsweise sogar vegan bis auf die
ich hinzufügen werde also falls ihr das
nach markt funktioniert auch super wenn
es vegan ist so parallel bringt rückten
ein kopf mit wasser zum kochen so
nachdem tofu schnappen wir uns ein
bisschen brokkoli den trend auch so ein
bisschen auf den brief dann nehmen wir
jetzt unsere angerosteten erstes und
wohl auch mal raus aus der pfanne nehmen
es ja auch schon ein paket von unseren
drei stunden und verteilt ihr einfach
hier in unserer fahne ideen wir gerade
an gebrüstet haben dies mittlerweile
wieder ein bisschen kühler und dann wird
es auch schon zeit unter kochendes
wasser dazugeben
in kochendem wasser ziehen hier zu zweit
einigung werde jetzt ziehen schneiden
wir eine karotte hinten vorne ab und
dann steigen wir so dünne scheibchen
raus wir wollen nämlich gleich für
karotten sticks raus machen hier immer
noch ein bisschen
die halbieren wir dann die karotten
scheiben und schneiden sie der länge
nach zur unter diesen speziellen
chinesischen knoblauch schnittlauch den
schneiden wir so 45 cm lang
da habe ich hier eine schalotte die
schnell so ein scheibchen ganz fein dann
wird jetzt auch zeit für unsere soße und
in der soße balancieren wir ganz viele
verschiedene geschmäcker aus wir fangen
an mit zwei esslöffeln ahornsirup vier
esslöffel sojasauce vier teelöffel
tamarinde passte und ein paar chili
faktor es verbinde ich jetzt und unsere
soße ist fertig dann machen wir uns auf
unseren blog an
neben dar ein polymer gehen wir jetzt
erstmal so zwiebeln hinein lassen jetzt
ein bisschen anschwitzen zwiebeln
angedünstet sind kommt auch unser
brokkoli dazu und der tofu und ich hätte
es fast vergessen wir gehen natürlich
noch ein bisschen limetten und fotos
also jetzt ist alles schön gestört jetzt
kommen auch unsere letzten zutaten ein
und zwar steht mit laub und eine gute
handvoll sojaschrot dann kommen auch
schon unsere nudeln dazu macht das
einfach mal einfach so und die soße
kommt
gut gut durch mengen damit auch über
also dran kommen dann müssen wir es
jetzt irgendwie schaffen uns hier so ein
bisschen platz zu machen unten und da
schlagen wir jetzt ein rein er das ist
wirklich so crazy was man in vier
portionen kocht sollte ich beruhigt so
viel platz wie es irgendwie geht für die
eier zu schaffen falle so voll und
dieses riesig also wird lassen wir alle
mal schön an backen sodann falten wir
jetzt auch genau hier durch dann zeigt
mir auch die nudeln drüber und werden
noch mal alles zusammen jetzt schon so
richtig schön diese klebrige konsistenz
ja sehr sehr nice leute bin gespannt
weil die mal ist wie gesagt sehr hoffe
das wird ihm schmeckt das abendessen im
bananenblatt serviert beim namen oder
bananen können keine an nachdem sie
erzählt hast dass du das authentische
partei kennst habe ich mein bestes
versucht ich bin sehr gespannt was du
sein willst nicht meinen teil und will
kommt man ja das schlimmste ist aber
wichtig ist ich denke ich marketing und
die liste sind sind die eier natürlich
nicht ganz nicht okay war ich habe auch
in der soße schon den elfmeter ist
hierzu limette normal dass man trotzdem
noch einfach nur so aus prinzip und auch
ein bisschen ja ja sogar den gesprochen
ja klar die sind auch länder aber auch
noch mal ich hab selbst bisschen dass
quargel war ja schon broker die saft
heute getrunken habe also man muss sagen
haben wir sollten sie schon gegessen
punkten
deswegen weil schon gesagt hat gelitten
hat gelitten
das heißt sagt es werden wieder nichts
gesagt oder nicht wir sehen sonst
wenngleich auch gegessen ist es ist
soweit auch dieser tag muss zu ende
gehen
interner komplett weggebrochen also ich
habe ja schon gesagt dass mein
lieblingsgericht was ist echt gut
hinbekommen
als strittig war ob wir wirklich
interessiert war seit er das tat was
habe ich gut hinbekommt von dem was du
gerne markt und habe ich was auch nicht
immer alles auf was auch ich standen die
konsistenz wie gut das gemüse ist ja
welches richter standard auch in
thailand immer so ein bisschen
wechselhaft zu machen die man
unterschiedliche sachen ja so gut dass
wir auch mal dran gemacht ist etwas was
wir auch hier in deutschland gesetzt die
mavericks die sommersprossen so also
eigentlich alles nahm das ganze paket
mit den optischen mieterbundes laptops
einzige was mir die filter der so ein
bisschen zusätzliches typisch asiatisch
vergeben wird so ein bisschen koriander
leichte schärfe chiliflocken aber das
ist so kleine nuance sind die auch
glaube ich vom geschmack abhängig sind
ja ich hätte insgesamt bei dem fall
keine tale leben wir aber den mindestens
eine ab und das ist graf war das ist ein
sehr schweres delikt bin ich fand sie
also die für mich war das allererste mal
dass ich überhaupt was aus der
thailändischen küche dafür kann ich
nachts wirklich sehen lassen weil ich
hab schon öfter bestellen und ich habe
nach einem restaurant einen kleinen
gesucht wo man gutes partei bekommen
keine chance eine die meisten sind
kleben zusammen betont klotz alter das
gemüse schon durch kochen bergen dort
richtig knackig hinbekommen die nudelbar
nicht ankleben erfolgreich ich kann hier
richtig klima ich hatte wirklich spaß
hat es war richtig cool einfach mal hier
für die ganze bande zu kochen
insbesondere für dich natürlich hat auch
spaß und wir sehen uns auf jeden fall
nächsten sonntag wieder für die nächste
folge ein tag persönlicher koch schaut
bei dir vorbei da kommt wie gesagt die
tage und damit max wo wir in sachen und
abonnieren ich bitte ich will vor dem
final
aber nicht nach